AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
*sploosh* Awww..
I made n' error. *ded*
EGRL, oh shiiit
*OOHF*
WELL.
WEGLUP
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHDN
WE'RE GOIN' FOR IT
*dies*
ahhhahha
WE'RE GONNA DIVE BOMB INTA *sploosh*
euowww..
EAT A FUCKIN
ow.
This got it.
No it dunn't
Ohhhh so grAACEFUL
*mumble* oh shit.
Gersh darnit
gersh
GERSH
ow
*Mark chanting something*
WHAAAA*victory noise*
*the wild markimoo is confused*
Da, duddn't count.
WOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOEYYYYYYYY*dies*yyyyyy....
CAAANNON BAAALL
OW
HOUGHAAAAA
*dies* fuck.
AAAAAAAAAAAND
WE
ARE
IIIIIIIIIIIIIN
HELL YEA!
Habuhbuh.
Take THAT Trump.
I mean literally take that.
Please take it.
Carry it with you.
And uh- maybe stab Santar behi-
*EXPLOSIONS*
I DIDNT DO ANYTHING!
I DID NOTHING!
I'M AN INNOCENT HERE!
IIIIAYOYYHAAH
I am a ninJAAA
fuck..
God dammit. This is literally impo-
There is lite-
There is no-
*irish accent-ish* There is NO way
There- GO HEAD GO
GO! GET THE COIN!
*Lion king theme song cover by Mark*
*Ded?* Ohhh..
I'M ALIV- *Dies Instantly*
Ah fuck God dammit *Laughing*
*SCHH*
I thought I had some hope the-here!
Oh good, they're fighting over my leg. *that's nice mark*
One of these days is- *gets impaled* gonna be good!
Eeeuuughhhhh....
GO HEAD GOOO!!
Either it's gonna fail or I am!
Or-or-or my grundle area is and then
it's gonna- *Sploads* - ah kay it was
Ah, kay it was the grundle..
GONNA GET IT! *explodes*
Mmm....
GO HEAD GO-
Ahhhhhh... shit.
*clickclickbam*
whuho ( GASP )
EETZ A DEEFERENT ROEP SWEENG!
( amazed markimoo sound )
OH IT'S SO PREEETY
NOES
( sigh of relief ) PLEASE
OLD MAN HELP ME
YOU MAGICAL
FLYING BEAST
PLEASE SWING-SWONG
MAH BODY
I'll give you my arm... it's tasty and delicious!
Don't know why I'm assuming you're a cannibal...
But... ( stutters ) ... maybe?
God if this stupid-
( Markimoo mating call )
uhhh fuck
Haboosky
Aw fuck
Ow. well...
heh
Ain't this a predicament.
Oooooh gosh.
Oh well.
Can't wait to tell the guys at the bar about this one-
aughhh
HAAAAA. There we go.
HAAAAAA
*British accent* I Got It!
yay
uh.
*Markimoo gets stuck*
*Markimoo tries to wiggle free*
*But it's not working!*
Come on! (The struggle is real)
NOOOO
Ahhhh there we go. we got it
we got it x3
we're good x2
Don't mind me, just doing the splits over here.
Can you grab- CAN YOU GRAB- AWWW FUCK
Alright, lets try this oonce mo-
Hey~ butt!
Aw fuck
"WWE move contest." I-
Gah fuck
I call this one...
"The Inverted Nun."
Can I hit you please?
I call this one "The Undulating Beaver"
Aaahh!!
Uh.
Hi.
I'm just gonna give you a smooch on the top of your head.
Oh, it's such a tender and romantic moment. Now if you wouldn't mind, just,
sucking something for me?!
I'm gonna call this one the, uh, the, jeez
Uh
Uh!
Uhh!
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Uhhh?!
I'm gonna call this one "The Unsure About My Feelings"
Um.
Haaaaap!
AAAAGGHHHH!
Ooh God...
Alright, Imma go this way-
This is a bad idea!!
Ugh!
Okay, I'm gonna try this one more time except less stupid-well fuck me.
Bweeh!!
Oooughh!!
Well!
Now I have this with me, forever and ever
Aaaghh!!
Come on! Get over! Aw, jeez, it's causing a bit of a
problem!
It's screwing up my arrow-dynamics!
Get it?
Fuck you! Gonna make it!
AAAAGHH!!
HO!!!
Harpoon run! Drawed Run.
Go for it!
I'm flying, ow.
Am I- I'm dead.
Hi-yaaahh... Ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow.
Ow.
Hi-yaaah... Oh okay bye so-oh-son we're going on
vacation.
okay have a good day at school
Ehhugghh...
Ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow
if I could just collect all these
harpoons inside my anUUs i just s-- WIIIIINNNN!!!
impossible two what's that?
Oh.
Impossible you s-ow. ImPOSSible you say im-de-de
pff fuck I just have to play this one again
because it's like the world's most
violent prostate exam
YEY! AAHHHH!
Ow. Alright son you stay there I'm
gonna get my weirdly magical legs.
Ok Lost an arm too but it's still
dangling by a weird attachment but ok
apparently mr. AK you're gonna come with
me because we've got some business to
sort out
I need to speak with your manager.
Could you ple-I'm trying to kick you off
but you eh-excuse me. you're being very rude
this whole establishment i need my
brains inside my head
Did you shoot at me I can't remember i'm very
drunk. And also i was recently stitched
together. you seem to be (long pause) specifically
aiming for my leg. And it somehow still
trying to pump
well now my arms gone at least if I got one
leg i still got hope.
oww. alright we're gonna we're gonna get
Ow.
Alright we're gonna-we're gonna get this
this i just need to stop losing so many lim-
I-I just need to stop losing so many li-
all right just stop being a dick
Stop it! Stop it stop.
FUCK!!! How about you shut up... Bitch. Oh
what's that huh
you missed me and hit the tw- ohh I don't know
what happened there everyone fell down.
That makes you extra stupid.
welp both legs gone Mike still going
get em Billy get him get him Billy...BILLY!
Miss the mortar miss the purge ok.
Don't have arms but when have I ever
needed arms before
( Markimoo mating call )
okay... we made it right... sniper
okay we made it right? SNIPER!
( Markimoo mating call )
Hey! I got all my limbs ey! I'm okay :D
oh this is going wonderful today.
Also I
seem to be going faster for some a bizarre
reason. ughhhh AWW CMON! I heard they're there there there i thought
AGhn
OO COME ON!
Her der der der~
ah!
NOM!
thought my brain was going to -xplode but it turns, i'm
my brain was gonna explode but it turns I'm
just dead anyway~
all right we're gonna get some speed now
please and and then John pop back by bag okay
ok. This has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
buh-bye!!